[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le faire et bien d'autres examens
pendant la pub ça va mon chéri senna y
fit wii et toi alors qu'amy contador on
annonce partout sur toutes les chaînes
sur toutes les radios des grosses
semaines voilà on t'annonce partout donc
voilà écoute on en sort un petit peu
plus jour un jour de février en vendée
sur la coiffure chéri mais là on est sur
une chaîne de rockabilly ou quand le
mondial de la coiffure tout va bien
alors on est sur le king master thème là
federer toi j'adore j'aime beaucoup de
tennis où est allé mon père et nadal et
moi je suis plus federer mais tu t'en
dos et tu prends toujours des combats
j'ai arrêté pour des raisons de niveau
que tu te fais des fils tu devais me
bats est vrai mais c'est impossible on
attend l'année prochaine bref même deux
ans j'ai pas me plaindre mais à quel
metois quand même bon voulait démarrer
oui les 24 antennes est très très rapide
vous allez voir pas le temps de dire ouf
et ce sera fini les bagnoles en fait
c'est tout ce qu'il fallait pas rater à
la télé ces dernières 24 heures les gens
mais ypres ajoute il ya du rythme de
dingue donc accompagné paix poussé par
an à l'émission de faustine bollaert et
en gratos au détour d'une phrase il a pu
se rendre compte à quel point ses
parents l'aident depuis le premier jour
quel âge votre fils parce que vous êtes
tout jeune oui on l'a eue à 17 ans à 17
ans n'était pas voulue elle
mr j12 aussi a décidé de déclarer sa
flamme par écrit mais c'est là qu'on
sente que jaja c'est pas le diminutif de
jacques attali à regarder en un mot il
ya quatre fautes d'amour et oui bah oui
on s'est aussi procuré leur liste de
courses 1 c'est pas brillant non pas du
ciel
je dors à dépasser les sept journalistes
anglais lé regard des lacets sérieux
elle a réalisé l'exploit de l'année elle
couvrait une course hippique il ya un
cheval qui a pris la fuite
et elle va l'arrêter seul savez vous
faire un truc de ouf
attention elle est forte incroyable
beaucoup de gens me demandent que fit
une grande diva comme benji castaldi a
pris une presta bas comme tout le monde
ivy de la pression en loge dans jamais
[Applaudissements]
normalisera il s'est lancé dans la
construction d'une cabane mais personne
lui a dit qu'il restait que 15 jours pas
besoin de chauffage au sol tout ça la
grosse fierté pour préparer la bouffe on
aura une chambre ici une chambre le
salon a marqué un appariement cela avec
la cuisine c'est une belle pièce de jeu
et on a reçu une image dans père je
voulais vous la montrer qu'il commence à
apprendre le golf à ses enfants ses
sympathies la première image aussi
mauvaise idée du gard ça peut que mal se
terminer
mais pas ce mois
[Applaudissements]
il arrive je monte je vois et c'est mon
fils c'est lui avons jamais te regarde
non mais sérieux il ya une regarde on
dirait qu'ils volent à la pyramide ddd
de khéops quoi va bien si bon bah c'est
bon et je voudrais dire depuis tout à
l'heure je crois que il se passe quelque
chose entre vous et gâte
elle arrête pas de le toucher
elle me gratter le tout avec une fille
me tripoli changé on est vraiment
étrange ne le prenez pas vos rêves pour
des réalités je ne change pas du tout
j'ai toujours les mêmes 2e objectif
d'ailleurs pas changé quand il faut la
paix isabelle je viens de vous voir ce
que j'avais pas regardé depuis le début
de l'émission puisque j'avais beaucoup
de choses à faire avec les avis vous
êtes très bien coiffée ah ça vous va
très bien la moto taxi ça m'arrange des
frais mais je vous jure que c'est vrai
mais non merci
non merci je voulais préciser pour
lebron est sous sa marque est un ami
voilà non c'est vrai marquez blessé
savait comment il s'appelle
[Applaudissements]
d'abord
vous connaissez ce qu'on a mais pas très
calme toi nous attendent et on sait
qu'au nouveau sport aux sports à la face
à moi ta grande gueule quoi il a croisé
au restaurant dit ça donne quoi vous
êtes reconnu e sport oui on est on est
amis on était amis c'est tout ça dans la
même salle watts d'artistes qui se
connaissent c'est grave alors tu t'en
alors les mêmes passions le sport
bah voila vous avait sympathisé c'est
vous qui êtes allés vers le bruit ou oui
je salue ouais mais ça je suis quelqu'un
de civilisés où ça va mais quoi cette
envie de me dire que vous êtes arrivé à
la sainte-baume effet marc lavoine vous
êtes matthieu delormeau quoi vous les
niches avait pas que la première fois
n'a pas été super quoi les i j'aime
beaucoup ce que vous faites vous l'avez
compris duvet qui voit là c'est vrai il
ya un fond de vérité
eh ben voilà excusez moi pas tu vas pas
nous on savait pas mais je suis content
d'en apprendre tu vas battant ouais je
m'attends très bien mon photographe très
grand très grand
photo ça faisait longtemps sur les
partis parlent avec des touristes dans
paris ça me fait du bien de retourner
dans la rue parce que la douche chien on
ne choisit pas de ses parents choisit
pas sa famille je ne dis pas non plus
les trottoirs de manille de paris au
d'alger pour apprendre à marcher pas nos
camions sur mélanie connard on essaie
d'apprendre aux étrangers a parlé le
petit adouna illustré et de répéter des
phrases indispensable à maîtriser pour
briller dans les couloirs de ses beats
regarde pas
pour les autres partis direct sur la
tour eiffel avant qu elle on à la
rencontre des dizaines et des dizaines
de touristes qui venaient du monde
entier car la fois que ce soit
américains japonais argentin tout le
monde parle le vocabulaire assez proche
de boussiers qui connaît fatah au plus
haut
jean michel aulas on va tout casser chez
toi beaucoup d'errements jamie tandy
zizi vous salue pas passé n'aura pas
tort c'est moi c'est nous qui t'aura de
verrous casque alp aide beaucoup et you
just repeat after me ok ok j'ai pas un
petit bug mais je peux en français
[Applaudissements]
alors comme d'hab je me suis mis à bas
la maison haïti petit which escalopes
bourse un rip de téléfoot aux camélias
le trac en ce moment avec la coupe du
monde qui arrive c'est christian
jeanpierre il a elle-même plus articulé
quand il pose une question on dirait
jean mi pendant le débrief de koh lanta
histoire de marketing je trouve faut pas
mélanger les choses se calment vous êtes
coach areola ou bouffonne dans les bus
de paris la nacion problème et puisqu'on
parle de fou transition on a récupéré
les images d'un match caritatif ont la
très belle association un jour meilleur
avec man star du ballon rond en sidney
govou eric carrière karim bennani
mais attendez mais c'est notre mot moque
mokhtar regarder ce futur ballon d'or
contrôle orienté coup du sombrero
inversée et hop passes décisives et but
tout est vrai mais après est arrivée la
tuile haouet cbc ouais ouais
mokhtar s'est blessé et ça va changer
beaucoup de choses on a pu le voir au 20
heures de tf1 ça tout remis en cause en
[Musique]
la première demi-heure du match il y
aura de cette finale cette impression
s'est aggravée qui n'a pas été blessé
que vous l'auriez sélectionnée c'était
un candidat sérieux
les 23 ans aujourd'hui des faits des
radios bon puis comme en ce moment j'ai
des rougeurs au bout des gouttes j'ai
regardé le mc de la santé cette reprise
boursière s'est déroulée au bout de
pratique c'est vrai ça arrive quand à
dire un riche art qui est un peu pénis
fait agréable cérès un autre gros couac
castaldi connaisse la paix mr gouttes au
qatar à 6 michel cymes il a tellement de
trojan soit il est de moins en moins
présents il ya son remplaçant qui fait
de son mieux pour remplacer michel mais
il est pas encore hyper à l'aise et il
tente quand même des vannes
donc c'est juste hyper gênant si vous
sentez un vent glacial selon votre
colonne vertébrale pendant cet extrait
c'est normal quand on voit cette petite
fille des milliers d'autres alors si ces
remarques alain calmât g pour la suite
le positif c'est pas forcément 1er et le
2 et le tir de paul eluard la terre est
bleue comme une orange a il a dit bleu
comme un paon mais il a mal dit les gens
ils ont compris orange
c'est dur c'est de préférer ces
d'économistes de sénou eric de
riedmatten
il a encore tenté de faire de l'humour
mais il est plus nasdaq d'archaos
passementiers tout ça c'est un coup du
vent qu'est-ce qu'on va dire pour
terminer que les italiens à tordre la
dolce vita
eh bien ils risquent de vivre le divorce
à l'italienne
métal interrogé des élèves concernant
les grèves dans l'éducation nationale et
sont tombés sur une enfant qui est très
en marche pas fan des grèves à 6 ans
pourrait déjà être député d'indre et
loire
c'est là c'est élèves de primaire
aimerait bien que le programme avance
plus rapidement
c'est tout le temps des gens des
graisses tout le temps du jour du vol je
suis même pas quand j'ai travaillé et
profits vont arrêter
moi j'aimerais bien qu'ils arrêtent
allègrement j'ai l'impression que c'est
le plus bel avion sans vacances d'abord
j'adore j'ai regardé les infos aussi de
9h50 9h50 de françois i recevait un
invité de ouf j'ai du mal à m'en
remettre
franchement que les foyers des
événements on s'en remet par ailleurs
puisque est ce qu'ils ont sur rihanna
barack obama mégane et harry rabbit et
surtout pour nous expliquer comment
soigner tout cela ensuite on appellera
une chèvre sur ce plateau
mais le journaliste de france info il
avait visiblement très fin ce matin à
prévoyez un petit buffet la prochaine
fois et en galère
une victoire pour wolfsburg est une
victoire pour lyon un petit mot
maintenant d'un tir ami intime remis à
tyrannosaur voilà junas benedetto lulu
un gros moment d'absence urnes pour jt
on l'a entendu dans les retours
[Musique]
pas vraiment
l'image du juge des mineurs ont été
placés il servi mais le meilleur c'est
dans le cadre d'une visite officielle
emmanuel macron il assiste à un discours
assez particulier on se demande quelle
idée la personne a voulu transmettre le
président marie public qui a convié des
acteurs à s'exprimer sous les eaux
[Musique]
c'est passé
[Applaudissements]
les intrus ouais tf1 m6 france 2 tmc on
m'envoie partout donc je les fais moi
même
regardez c'est les a prises soient
directement dans les émissions télé pour
être sûr de tous ordres à manquer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
to be my man tu as
tous à ntoum up haute inverse del rio
c'est tabou alors défenseur adil rami
djibril sidibé le lieu de terrain ngolo
quand et blaise matuidi
paul pogba attaquant ousmane dembélé
nabil cqeer olivier giroud antoine
griezmann 20 ans après sa mort trois
visages en salles le 6 juin marqué
l'entrée en compétition des jafar panahi
toujours à sarkozy dont c'est mulhouse à
5h58 dame venue à tous que tout à fait
qu'ils aient tout votre sentiment vous
qui résidait depuis maintenant de
longues années correspondant évidemment
pour l'info de france 2 à londres votre
sentiment sur le rapport entre la
famille royale et meghan markle
[Applaudissements]